voici le spectacle le plus prisé de
cette fin de siècle le football
véritable industrie avec ses vedettes
achetées à prix d'or par des clubs
transformés en entreprise
[Musique]
les télévisions du monde entier se
ruinent pour leur acheter ces images
les sponsors se bousculent les stades se
comblent et les audiences s'envolent
[Musique]
la machine à produire de l'argent tourne
aujourd'hui à plein régime c'est le
triomphe du football business
[Musique]
ce fut le feuilleton de l'été le
transfert de l'année
Nicolas Anelka 20 ans attaquant
prometteur a été acheté par le club
espagnol du Real Madrid au club anglais
d'Arsenal
montant 220 millions de francs je
regarde pas les millions de façons ils
sont pas pour moi premièrement exact
cette Arsenal qui encaisse l'argent payé
en plusieurs trades pendant quatre ans
par le Real et moi ça me fait rien du
tout moi je suis là pour jouer je suis
venu j'ai signé je suis là pour m'amuser
sur le terrain et c'est tout
un amusement pour lequel le jeune homme
aperçut une prime de bienvenue 40
millions de francs il touche aussi
chaque mois un salaire d'un million
800.000 francs net d'impôts hors prime
de match
c'est sur la base de ce salaire qui a
été calculé la commission de l'agent
d'Anelka marque Roger et c'est le Real
Madrid qui lui a versé 3 millions et
demi de francs à peine selon Marc Roger
de quoi couvrir ses frais de jet privé
d’autelux et d'avocats
[Musique]
de Madrid soit de faire une plus-value
soit dans tous les cas on met de faire
un retour sur investissement c'est quoi
un retour sur investissement sur un
jouet si Nicolas Deca joue 4 ou 5 ans au
Real de Madrid on met le jour il part
s'il repart pour pour la même sombre
mais effectivement le Real Madrid
récuperera son investissement donc c'est
un petit peu en retour sur
investissement
ce genre de calcul que font les
présidents de clubs quand ils saignent
le contrat certaines pour pas dire la
plupart
c'est transferts sont donc avant tout
des opérations commerciales qui
enrichissent tout le monde et surtout
les clubs ce qui vendent et en poche
l'argent ce qui achète pour attirer
publique et télévision les joueurs eux
réclament des salaires mirobolants
pourquoi se priver les grands clubs ont
les moyens ils sont de mieux en mieux
gérer à l'image du plus rentable d'entre
eux Manchester United
[Musique]
voici peut-être le magasin le plus
fréquenté de la ville la boutique du
club ne supporters vient assouvir sa
passion pour la marque Manchester United
200 francs la lampe 100 francs le pyjama
enfant et meilleure vente absolue le
maillot de l'équipe 450 francs
pourquoi achetez-vous ce maillot
ce que je veux le porter pendant les
matchs
vous êtes fan de Manchester bien sûr oui
depuis très longtemps depuis combien
d'années
[Musique]
un peu plus de 60 ans
une autre boutique comme celle-ci a
ouvert à Dublin et bientôt à Singapour
Hong Kong Bangkok le Caire Manchester
United ce rêve en multinationale avec
ses 200 clubs officiels de supporters
consommateurs de par le monde
l'an dernier les fans sont venus
dépenser au magasin et au musée plus de
2 milliards de francs 20% des recettes
du club
[Musique]
la visite du stade elle aussi est un
modèle d'efficacité et de rentabilité
économique un circuit parfaitement rodé
allez qui veut des pellicules
tenez cette rente franquiez allez tenez
l'entrée elle coûte 60 francs par
personne il n'y a pas de tarif enfant
des groupes de 50 visiteurs se succèdent
toutes les 10 minutes de 10h à 17h sans
interruption
rapporte de l'argent les visites ont
lieu toute l'année sauf à Noël et les
jours de match
depuis 9 ans que Manchester United est
coté à la Bourse de Londres la valeur de
l'action a été multipliée par cette une
bonne affaire les profits du club sont
gigantesques que ça notoriété
extraordinaire mais sa taille modeste
535 salariés seulement bref l'entreprise
idéale pour les spécialistes financiers
sur l'argent gagné par le club environ
300 millions de francs une toute petite
partie a été versée aux actionnaires en
guise de dividendes
mustv l'essentiel a été investi dans le
stade vous l'avez vu il construisent
12000 places supplémentaires
mais aussi dans l'achat de joueurs comme
York Stan blockwist et d'autres
les dirigeants suivent aussi un
important programme de formation pour
les jeunes joueurs
ainsi Manchester United et sans aucun
doute le meilleur exemple au monde ne se
football business envahi
cet argent à am et les résultats pour
preuve l'équipe a gagné la Ligue des
Champions en Europe
en Grande-Bretagne 22 clubs sont cotés
en bourse pour la plupart chiffre
d'affaires et profit augmentent
régulièrement c'est l'air de l'opulence
le football change l'économie change
alors nous pouvons plus dire c'était si
bien il y a 10 ans quand il y avait ni
place assise ni toilette ni confort
certains aujourd'hui regrettent une
hypocrévolue je crains fort pour eux que
le monde échangé
le football tire son argent des
télévisions des sponsors
tout cela impose donc une comptabilité
et une gestion responsable des clubs
[Applaudissements]
mais la toute nouvelle richesse des
clubs provient surtout des droits de
retransmission qu'il vendent au
télévision
désormais c'est à coup de milliards de
francs que les télés européennes comme
stream en Italie s'arrachent le précieux
spectacle
créer une assise en stream est une
télévision privée payante par abonnement
diffusé par câble et satellite
en mai dernier le milliardaire
australien repère Murdoch propriétaire
de nombreuses chaînes en Europe a pris
le contrôle de stream
la stratégie alors changé stream malgré
ses dettes a offert un pont d'or à 7
clubs italiens pour diffuser leur match
de championnat un milliard de francs par
an pendant six ans
notre chaîne avait besoin d'un produit
fort pour se lancer sur le marché
il était absolument impensable de le
faire sans le football qui est en Italie
un phénomène culte
et avec le cinéma et les matchs de
l'équipe nationale il y a un grand
produit et c'est le championnat italien
nous ne pouvions pas attirer des abonnés
sans le football c'était tout bonnement
impensable c'est vraiment l'arme fatale
sur tous les marchés en Europe et encore
plus en Italie
cette somme 6 milliards en six ans peut
paraître exorbitante elle ne l'est pas
aux yeux des dirigeants de la chaîne
c'est à dire que nous sommes partis nous
avions une croissance de 700 à 1000
abonnés par jour du jour même nous avons
eu le football même une partie du
football pas le football entier nous
sommes en train de croître à quatre fois
ça 4000 par jour moyenne ce qui fait que
nous avons doublé à la fin de septembre
nos objectifs de l'année donc nous
sommes plus que 300000 abonnés et nous
comptons de continuer à croître de cette
façon
stream ne gagnera de l'argent que dans 6
ans juste à l'issue du contrat avant de
nouvelles enchères où les clubs se
montreront sans doute encore plus
gourmand
qu'importe les audiences sont
excellentes en Italie comme en Espagne
en Allemagne en Angleterre ou en France
le public n'a jamais autant regardé de
matchs et n'en a jamais autant demandé à
l'antenne les études de marché ne
prévoient aucun ralentissement sans
faire jusqu'au jour où la belle
mécanique des failles ou l'argent
devient le seul enjeu
sont deux sur lui il va falloir l'aider
là parce que le son caverne des
commentaires était déjà un mauvais
présage ce jour-là Monaco joue en
Pologne contre lot France 2 retransmet
la rencontre du moins pendant les 25
premières minutes car soudain voilà un
coup c'est pour la forme
la
c'est pour la précision
et ça vient d'arriver pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la télé un match
est interrompu apparemment pour des
problèmes de droit de télévision de
droit de sport c'est droit le club de
Lodz les a d'abord vendus à une société
en contrat avec France 2 mais quelques
heures avant le match un groupe européen
de communication concurrents a fait une
offre plus alléchante aux responsables
du club qui ont donc fait couper le
faisceau en direct France 2 a perdu près
de 10 millions de francs d'écran
publicitaires non diffusé
un programme habituel sur France 2 que
vous suivez à peu près à cette heure-là
tous les jours cette Hartley cœur à vif
l'argent c'est grâce à lui que l'équipe
de Lyon dispute ce soir un match de
Coupe d'Europe il y a 10 ans le club
jouait en deuxième division
c'est que Jean-Michel Aulas le président
a beaucoup investi surtout cette saison
il a acheté des stars comme Sonia
Anderson 120 millions de francs ou Tony
vers elle 60 millions
[Musique]
Michel Aulas a surtout cherché un
partenaire financier un grand groupe en
quête d'investissement rentable
le président croit au succès et au
profit c'est un chef d'entreprise sans
état d'âme
il y a le sportif on l'a vu ce soir et
puis à côté il y a tout ce que la
gestion d'un club tournait vers ses
actionnaires vers ces salariés doit
pouvoir apporter sur le plan économique
et là il y a pas photo il faut que ça
soit l'économie qui dirige et l'économie
c'est effectivement avoir des comptes
équilibrés et si possible bénéficiaire
créer les conditions du succès il faut
pouvoir créer les conditions d'une
économie saine il faut être dans un
bassin de population qui est important
il faut savoir attirer aussi des
investisseurs comme on a essayé de le
faire et puis un ensemble d'entreprises
qui participent puisque comme c'est un
spectacle et bien les entreprises
veulent participer sont prêtes à payer
largement
ce gros investisseur c'est le groupe de
cinéma Pathé principal actionnaire de
l'Olympique Lyonnais
son président Jérôme Seydou n'a pas
souhaité nous recevoir il ne s'est pas
rendu non plus au conseil
d'administration du club où nous avons
rencontré le numéro 2 du groupe lui ne
jure que par le divertissement
l'entertainment c'est une société
d'entertainment
dans lequel on est depuis très très
longtemps et c'est aussi le sport et on
est présent dans le sport maintenant
avec une chaîne qui s'appelle patate
sport et pensant qu'il était important
de nous rapprocher d'un club prestigieux
comme comme l'Olympique Lyonnais
important précisément pour la conquête
de ces fameux droits télévisées
aujourd'hui en France les clubs de
première division se partagent
équitablement le pactole versé par les
chaînes question de solidarité entre
petits et grands solidarité qui pourrait
bien disparaître lors des prochaines
négociations des droits car les grands
clubs qui font les meilleures audiences
veulent imposer leur logique chacun pour
soi chacun ses droits Pathé à Lyon ou M6
à Bordeaux espère diffuser un jour sur
leur propre chaîne les images de leur
propre club
acheteurs aujourd'hui les groupes
veulent devenir vendeur de mains en
contrôlant toute la filière malheur au
club qui ne trouveront pas de telles
repreneurs
[Applaudissements]
acquérir un club pour en diffuser les
matchs c'est exactement ce qu'attenté
Rupert Murdock l'homme d'affaires a
proposé 6 milliards de francs pour que
sa chaîne Biscaye rachète Manchester
United l'offre a été acceptée par les
dirigeants mais invalidé par le
gouvernement avec Manchester be skylie
n'aurait sans doute plus diffusé comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui les matchs
d'autres équipes moins attractives
commercialement
l'affaire a laissé des traces aucun
responsable du club n'a accepté de nous
en parler même cet homme Alex Ferguson
l'entraîneur souvent critique à l'égard
de ses propres dirigeants n'a pas voulu
aborder la question y compris hors
caméra
eux sont plus bavards supporters de
Manchester United depuis l'enfance ils
en sont aussi actionnaires 50 titres à
peine mais qu'il n'aurait vendu pour
rien au monde à Murdoch
nous possédons une toute petite partie
du capital mais ça signifie que cette
partie ne tombera jamais entre les mains
des grands financiers c'est aussi simple
que ça nous ne vendrons jamais ces
actions quel que soit leur valeur en
êtes-vous sûr absolument sûr à 100%
monsieur pourquoi parce que j'aime
Manchester pas l'argent
l'été dernier l'équipe est allée jouer
en Chine et en Australie prétexte pour y
signer d'importants contrats commerciaux
dans une nouvelle compétition une coupe
du monde des clubs et pour ça ils ont
décidé de ne pas disputer la Coupe
d'Angleterre la plus ancienne de toutes
les coupes Manchester tenant du titre ne
jouera pas pourtant l'an passé les
meilleurs matchs auxquels nous avons
assisté c'était les matchs de la Coupe
d'Angleterre contre Liverpool Arsenal
des vrais matchs
cette saison les supporters ne verront
pas ces matchs parce que l'équipe va
jouer au Brésil uniquement pour que les
dirigeants de la société Manchester
United puissent développer la marque du
club en Amérique du Sud
ce qui compte pour eux c'est le marché
sud-américain pas les supporters voilà
leur priorité
ce soir là Marc et Monica ont quand même
assisté au match joué en l'honneur
d'Alex Ferguson 200 francs la place
recette en partie versée à des œuvres de
charité
vous ne verrez aucune image de ce match
amical le club en a chèrement vendu les
droits à Biscaye à Manchester United la
charité à ses limites
nous sommes au centre d'entraînement de
la Lazio de Rome
ici les dirigeants ne sont pas eux non
plus des philanthropes mais bien des
industriels la famille crâniotti à la
tête d'un groupe de produits
alimentaires numéro un de la sauce
tomate à acheter le club en 92 ces stars
sont aujourd'hui parmi les mieux payés
d'Europe c'est que les craniotis voient
grand transformer la Lazio sur le modèle
de Manchester
trois objectifs
premièrement la cotation en bourse la
construction deuxièmement la
construction du centre d'entraînement
qui est en train d'être terminée
et la construction et enfin la
construction d'un nouveau stade
exclusivement pour la Lazio un stade
multifonction avec un centre commercial
des cinémas des restaurants des
boutiques un supermarché
toute la semaine
les granotis possèdent la moitié du
capital de la Lazio l'autre moitié a été
introduite en Bourse l'an passé un vrai
succès les supporters se sont rués sur
les actions
toujours pour 150000 francs et parce que
j'avais confiance en notre président
cranioti
et je connaissais la direction qu'il
allait donner au club je suivais ce
qu'il faisait dans son entreprise ça a
été une bonne affaire
[Applaudissements]
j'ai acheté autant par spéculation par
amour
c'était le premier club italien côté
Hambourg les actions ont doublé c'était
valable
depuis que craignenti est arrivé
beaucoup de choses ont changé
il nous a amenés vers les titres qu'on
attendait depuis 1974
nous devons beaucoup à ce président
c'est supporter actionnaires achètent et
ventes en fonction des résultats de leur
équipe une contreperformance et c'est le
courant bourse qui chute démonstration
c'était en mai dernier la Lazio joue à
Florence match décisif la victoire
assurerait quasiment à la Lazio le titre
de champion tu reviens alors l'action
litigieuse
l'arbitre n'a pas vu la faute sur
l'attaquant romain salace il ne sifflera
pas penalty score final un but partout
le grand rival le Milan AC du
milliardaire Silvio Berlusconi sera
champion
conséquence dès l'ouverture de la Bourse
le lundi suivant le cours Lazio
s'effondre certains actionnaires
décident alors de poursuivre en justice
l'arbitre et les juges de touches pour
dommage économique la plainte n'aboutira
pas mais l'idée est lancée il y a
plusieurs
montre bien qu'il n'y a aucun
favoritisme à l'égard de la ladio on ne
lui fait aucun cadeau la laggio doit
obtenir la victoire sur le terrain alors
que d'autres équipes elles ne gagnent
pas uniquement grâce au terrain
le patron de la Lazio qui accueille
volontiers dans sa tribune leader
d'extrême droite John francofini ici en
bas à droite de l'écran fait allusion
aux enquêtes menées actuellement en
Italie sur des matchs truqués
mais les juges s'intéressent aussi aux
propres cas de Sergio crâniotti
soupçonnés de fraude phosphatures et
constitution de caisse noire pour la
construction du centre d'entraînement de
la Lazio une affaire dans laquelle il a
déjà été condamné pour irrégularité
comptable
[Musique]
politique phosphatures voilà qui
rappelle l'histoire d'un autre président
de club
Bernard Tapie à l'Olympique de Marseille
[Applaudissements]
pour gagner la Coupe d'Europe ce soir de
mai 93 l'homme d'affaires avait recruté
des vedettes qu'il rémunéré
généreusement
ses adjoints avaient aussi acheté un
match quelques jours plus tôt ce fut le
scandale Valenciennes Marseille
depuis Bernard Tapie condamné pour sa
gestion de l'OM a quitté le monde du
football
les clubs français eux ont vu leur
compte passer au crible et leur finance
assainies
mais la corruption n'est pas le seul
danger le football business impose
désormais aux joueurs un rythme
démentiel jusqu'à trois matchs par
semaine pour tenir seule solution le
dopage
nous nous sommes rendus au Club des
Girondins de Bordeaux repris récemment
par des financiers de la chaîne M6
chaîne qui se Vantage à 10 de ne pas
diffuser de football
cette saison Bordeaux dispute la Ligue
des champions dont les droits télé ont
déjà rapporté 30 millions de francs en
match
cette compétition s'ajoute au
championnat à la coupe à la Coupe de la
Ligue et pour certains on rencontre de
l'équipe de France
[Musique]
Jérôme bonicell lui refuse le dopage
mais il ose en parler avec inquiétude
vraiment en particulier
quand j'aurai 30 ans quoi
donc bon ça c'est chacun chacun de ces
intelligence du joueur mais c'est vrai
que bon au niveau de au niveau de la
c'est surtout au niveau de la
récupération c'est ça c'est ce qu'il
faut bon là on a joué hier on rejoue
samedi on rejoue après mercredi c'est
des cadences de fou donc après bon il
faut pas s'étonner que bon on essaye et
que certaines joueurs essayent à trouver
des moyens pour récupérer et pour et
aussi pour pour être dans l'attente de
ce que demain les dirigeant et de ce que
demande de public moi je me rappelle
avant on demande six mois un joueur pour
s'acclimater maintenant c'est terminé
c'est terminé quand on joue tous les
trois jours c'est sûr qu'on peut pas
s'entraîner comme quand on joue une fois
par semaine est-ce que c'est cadence
infernale comme vous dites ne risque pas
d'augmenter les risques de dopage je
sais pas moi j'ai jamais connu le dopage
je peux pas vous dire maintenant comme
je vous ai dit on a un certifié
un service médical
au point au point de du du de du fait et
il donne aux joueurs ce qu'il faut
donner en restant dans la légalité pour
pour récupérer pour être bien et
maintenant si on en arrive là ça serait
dramatique il faut pas que ça on en
arrive là surtout pas surtout pas on en
est pas là j'ai jamais connu ça et j'ai
pas connu ça dans le football non jamais
moi alors je peux pas vous dire je sais
pas
le dopage fléau du cyclisme et de
l'athlétisme est-il autant répandu dans
le football pas encore réponds
Jean-François bourse spécialiste de
l'économie du sport mais ce n'est qu'une
question de temps le problème du dopage
il est inscrit dans la logique du
football business dans la mesure où les
confrontations sont de plus en plus
nombreuses de plus en plus de haut
niveau forcément et il faut que le
joueur prenne des produits pour
augmenter donc sa capacité à récupérer à
supporter des douleurs parce que
l'entraînement est de plus en plus
difficile donc on est dans une logique
américaine à savoir que le dopage à mon
avis va être banalisé aux États-Unis il
n'y a pas de véritable recherche du
dopage on cherche la drogue on considère
que le sport professionnel est un
spectacle au même titre que d'autres
activités économiques et donc on
considère que la performance sportive
n'est pas entachée par un quelconque
absorption de produits dopants
il y a quatre mois le joueur de
Marseille Christophe Dugarry a comparu
devant la Fédération un contrôle d'urine
avait révélé la présence d'un produit
dopant mais le contrôle avait été bâclé
le médecin n'était pas assermenté ce
vice de forme a innocenté le joueur
Christophe Dugarry a d'ailleurs menacé
d'arrêter sa carrière en cas de
sanctions personne dans le milieu ni a
intérêt le football business a besoin de
ses vedettes on est dans une phase de
transition vers un modèle américain de
ligue fermée ou il n'y aura que des
matchs de haut niveau et des matchs très
lucratifs où il y aura des taux
d'audience très élevés chaque chaque
match que signifie League fermé à Olli
fermé c'est une ligue qui a été
envisagée par mediapartner dans un
groupe financier donc italien soutenu
par Berlusconi et par Murdoch notamment
c'est une ligue donc à laquelle on
accède ce des critères financier
médiatique et non pas des critères
sportifs autrement dit on se qualifie
pas pour y entrer et en plus on a aucune
aucun risque de quitter cette Liga
autrement dit elle est stable sur cinq
ans on prend les 18 meilleurs clubs
d'Europe il n'y a pas de montée ou
descente donc c'est système américain
Luc fermé stable qui permet évidemment
de garantir des revenus très très élevés
et qui rassure les marchés financiers
parce que l'aléa sportif est gommé
la Ligue des Champions ressemble déjà à
ce modèle américain les clubs les plus
riches de chaque pays sont assurés de
s'affronter pour la plus grande
satisfaction des télévisions
prochaine étape un véritable championnat
d'Europe qui creusera davantage l'écart
entre grand et petit club
les valeurs sportives de confrontation
loyale d'incertitude du résultat
d'épanouissement du joueur sont donc peu
à peu supplantés par les notions
d'exploitation et de rentabilité avec
leur dérive corruption et dopage
l'argent risque de vaincre
définitivement la beauté du jeu
[Musique]